gang we're about to kick off the second
leg of that state trashy tour oh yeah
coming into the home stretch so don't be
left out in the cold make sure you get
your tickets stand up comedy plus you
play the ly with the crowd great way to
introduce two people to the show so grab
the squad come out and see the boys yeah
guys we're going to be in uh Pittsburgh
Buffalo Toronto we're do we just added a
third show in Toronto get tickets for
that cuz they're moving we got Pontiac
Michigan Chicago Illinois fourth show
being added there get those tickets
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
Sacramento San Francisco San Jose then
we're we're we're ending it and Philly
baby with a bang we added a second show
with the Filmore that's more than
halfway sold out get those tickets let's
party go Birds welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to to everybody's new
favorite podcast this is R you garbage
oh yeah it's that little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that if they grow up to be classy
yeah or they just a big old piece of
trash trash I'm your host a Foley coming
at you on a rainy day we're out back
here with toies in the new edition she's
upstairs just slipped into a nice warm
bath okay and her jeans don't know why
all right fair enough okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he's
the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman but always the
king of the boardwalk baby give it up
for KJ Kevin James what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you Rie subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are true cooking baby and then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com garbage gang check it
out it's a [__] party over there and
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works to ones the
twos the threes and the fours he crosses
the t's and he dots the eyes give it up
for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby McMullan
everybody what up boys I'm excited we
got we got got a legend in here
man a guy who really will let you know
why your shirt
stinks he was sitting here for about 30
seconds started touching
stuff [__] Geico man [__] trashing
me cave man Jesus Christ man [__]
2year run on a makeover
show not in a bad way I like it gang the
long hair ain't lying cuz couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly and
I mean incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time we've
wanted to have him for a while we're
very excited he is a legendary standup
comedian actor writer and podcaster and
you might have seen him in but not
limited to you got the Chappelle show
American Dreams top five Jim Gaffigan
show the king of Staten Island de Comedy
Jam Showtime at the Apollo tough crowd
Jimmy Kimmel Last Comic Standing he's
got two Comedy Central presents live at
Gotham world's dumbest comedy.tv the Jim
Norton Show Parts Unknown The Joe Rogan
Experience WTF cop show this week at the
comedy Celler of course Opie and Anthony
he has an amazing podcast my wife hates
me and he's got a brand new special out
right now 30 minutes with Rich Voss give
it up for the legend Rich Voss there he
is this is [__] amazing because uh
you forgot evening at the
impr he also wrote for the Oscars twice
twice uh which every time I've seen him
he's told me
but be happy I talk to you uh the [__]
is wrong with you I acknowledge you what
the [__] uh wait the first day of my
first day I've ever was in New York it
was 10 years ago I was at the stand he
walks out I'm like holy [__] there's
Rich v he's like who are you Monroe
Martin like oh this is my buddy he just
moved to New York and you're like see
that what the b or something at the time
he's like you see that over there I'm
like yeah he's like go pull it up for me
I'm like all right I was like I guess
this is how New York Comedy Works so I
went to grab his key like get the [__]
out of here steal my car we were such
[__] oh I know like at the Celler
like you guys came up from Philly and
like we would sit I don't I don't Kevin
was already at our table with you know
Patrice me Keith Colin Norton and I
remember you and like four other comics
from Philly maybe rest in peace Chris
came and you all came around me and
started [__]
smashing I remember that night I beat of
you know he's going he's going I'll take
how many more [__] you got out
there bus pulls up out front uh but they
they go let's get V they would they
wouldn't [__] with Patrice or you know
uh so funny it was I I don't know like
if if people people did hate us sure
like but people said that they're just
[__] [__] having you know what I
mean I guess every crew that was the
table we wanted to be at we always loved
you cuz that's we came up all you guys
were like just the older were like
that's where you want to be you want to
be like we did the same thing just
around the corner at the Village Lantern
yeah
every
no I I would imag I think now it's there
just it's so much more lighter or we you
know Comics AR you know they're scared
to say something or I said something to
some comic one day at the seller and and
it
was some guy was on a guy code or
whatever and they rebooted it and I said
some joke and he goes what's that about
and I was like what's that about you
thin skin [__] bodak shut the what's
that about I'll tell about B Act is good
I got to take Dramamine talking to you
okay you [__] stink uh but you know
there I I I have sent apologies
onil like like I used to think when
Foley stared at me I used to think oh
this guy wants to kill me what did I do
to him no not at all that's [__]
hilarious oh man I'm sorry no please you
guys from Philly though you guys came up
and just took New York by storm there
was a lot of us thank you yeah there was
a few waves of us and you know everybody
was very hardworking it was like you
know it was very everybody was just like
[__] beating the pavement you know
well that's how we were the Jersey com
like when me Florentine Norton mainly I
I mean came from Jersey and just started
working all the clubs in New York m
[__] taking waitresses in the back
you know everybody's going look at these
[__] scumbags fromd tunnel come here
take my women oh they were such they
they hated us hated us stealing the
ketchup knock taking their women in
their spots I get it oh look at these
Jersey scumbags you know uh [__] well to
be fair it was you Norton and Florentine
it wasn't you guys aren't the Kennedy's
rolling in to the [__] comic strip
V [__] three creeps rolling that's a
good point every put your hand on your
wallet that's a good point he's leaving
a room I'm leaving a room clap so we
know he's not
stealing no it I guess it's to every
group and just you just see it sure now
uh you know the the transformation in I
guess every business but mainly in
comedy you know uh with clubs on the
road and you know some clubs just now
they go you know I said I want more
money they go these were your numbers
this is what you sold and I wanted to
email back no that's what you sold my
job is to be funny okay if I wanted to
get into [__] promotions or or
whatever I'm not you know what I me not
a marketing guy I'm not a p yeah
marketing thank you I'm not the briad to
see I should it should have been
marketing but this [__] dumb Jew bag
over here me ah would have said
something stupid anyhow it my allowed to
say that about myself no of course I've
been saying it all
day hell is it why you talk to the
building owner
uh you know what I mean so it's just
it's a whole new like
during [__] when I was when all of us or
if I was when I was doing tough crowd or
Last Comic or any of those shows back
then if we had Instagram and Twitter you
know what I mean we'd [__] be
sure it just we didn't have the door
yeah you know the it two years a tough
crowd if we had Instagram you know yeah
that was such a big show of course you
know and that
show uh groundbreaking crazy it a
podcast it was a TV podcast so many
people Comics would come up to me and
I'm sure everybody else on I used to
watch that you know you guys are the
reason I did comedy and I go don't blame
me all right stop tell your parents I'm
sorry but you know what I mean it was
just it was there was nothing like it I
mean it was you know Bill Marshall but
it wasn't like [__] tough crowd no
Comics being Comics busting other's
balls and talking [__] and that's what
we learn that's what we thought Comics
were I was like yeah that's I mean we
were doing that stuff with our own
friends growing up and you're like oh
that's what comedy is I like I sit
around and break balls you know yeah
it's it's you know it's fun I mean we
used to stand
outside Boston Comedy Club mainly it was
like usually at the end of the night it
was me
Patrice Keith Robinson and Norton
mhh to 300 in the morning
smashing laughing and you know else was
gone depalo was gone Bill K Colin you
know whatever and we we were just like
the last four when no girlfriends or
lives just [__] trash making fun of
each other on the street all night long
that's what we did too we got up here we
for you guys yeah it's a good time it's
fun that's I look back and that was so
much fun that I had in comedy yeah I
mean with Pat me and Patrice I mean this
uh just you know driving them back back
to Jersey City and we're walking to his
apartment I was going to I just told the
story but we're walking up to his
apartment and he looks at me and goes I
don't have an agent I can't get work I
got nothing happening I go you I can't
[__] no one's hiring me and and we
what we don't and then we just both
started cracking up and kept walking you
know you know just what the [__] just is
what it is baby yeah let's go back give
us the uh give us the backstory of Rich
Voss childhood who Jersey born and
raised Jersey born in uh planfield New
Jersey I grew up well I mean go I ended
up in planfield I was always in
Playfield but in an urban section okay
uh like my I would come home from school
in fourth grade nine years and I would
listen to this comedy album Von meter he
did the he did impressions of Robert and
John Kennedy okay biggest comic back
biggest career MH number one album
seller Kennedy's were shot career over
oh [__] talking about pigeon ho holding
yourself this guy went from Park Avenue
to park bench he was he did it's just
saying he went sure and did day Kennedy
was assassinated Lenny Bruce went on
stage and said well there go there goes
Von meter's career damn he said it that
night diversify I used to come out from
school and listen to that album every
day was it a house was it an apartment a
shitty apartment my mom raised and it it
hit me later on life I'm leave I'm
listening to this to cover the pain of
my parents divorce sure of my father who
my father who passed away July
31st which was my daughter's birthday 16
July and I'm like happy birthday
Grandpa's Dead uh [__] narcissist
dies on my daughter's birthday yeah
Jesus Christ so you know one last screw
job he he was nowhere to be found I you
know to come every couple weeks see is
you know I were they ever together your
parents they were and they got divorced
yeah but when you were young yeah I was
like nine years old and how many were in
the house well did you have brothers and
sisters yeah my brother and my sister
how old are they uh he's dead he passed
away okay uh all doom and gloom with
this guy know Jesus wait till you hear
about my dead
career you know got an airport story or
something light this up a little bit you
do comedy right be funny talk about
abortion anyhow how much older was he
than you no I he was two years younger
and my sister's a couple years older
okay who
is Major money in life and did well okay
so my mom raised us now we moved above
my after bouncing around every [__]
place in town cuz my mom was a secretary
raising three kids you know she had no
[__] I mean she went to college but a
secretary we my grandparents owned a
multif family house okay so we lived on
on the second floor for free luckily
nice I shared a room with my brother my
mother and sister shared a room okay but
my grandparents own the house and it was
like they were you know and the block
behind me was in front the front of the
house was on the corner the front of the
house was mixed white people in houses
black but the the back the side street
was all black okay where I grew up
because one I was always in I always
felt I didn't belong I always felt well
I wasn't good enough for them but I'm
okay here because just's a lot of broken
homes and a lot of dysfunction at least
connected you connected with them more
yeah at least that's how I perceive
things so I grew up you know hanging out
at Rudy's house going there Friday
because I knew his mom was cooking
[__] fried fish you know and try to
get a plate a free plate of food sure
you know you know Green and you know
block parties we had you know and I was
the white kid and there was a couple
others that would come around we played
Sports and you know so I grew
up always feeling not a part of sure
gotcha even when I hung and I had a lot
of friends I grew up playing sports I
was good uh you know and then you you
start hanging you always hung with
dysfunctional kids sure yeah you know
because that's I knew you know I smok
and pot and I worked my way you know
becoming a [__] free based crack
addict you know years later it's a good
way to put it working your way up I put
in the ear I put in years I just start
overnight I'm not one of these Tik Tock
Sensations I was working the road this
was a lot of work dime bags 20 bags you
know and after my mom it took me time to
realize what a struggle she had in life
sure it takes you I think you have to
get older in perspective of like once
you start earning and making a living
you're like holy [__] did just ever get
out of that or were you always in that
apartment was at your grandparents yeah
always and then until I got old enough
to leave you know I mean Thursday night
was you know she' give us a dollar and a
quarter and we go get subs on Thursday
night you know and I always had to get
spiced ham and cheese or belong I never
had the money to get roast beef and
turkey and I be with friends I get roast
beef and turkey and I'm like what the
[__] why can't I get roast beef and it's
so dumb you thinking but you know God
she struggled my mother to race to raise
three kids on a you know and I was a
[__] [__] smoking P you know doing
drugs I had a I smashed her car you know
I was in New York when night well one
dude I owed drug money he he burnt
torched her car I owed him
Jes cartel what the [__] no this is when
I was in my 20s you know I still when I
was a drug addict you know I stayed at
my mom she moved now she had an
apartment okay cuz her parents died her
brother and sister sold the house and
you know had to get out did she get a
little piece of that I think so sure
broke it up [__] her that bad gotcha you
know and uh you know I stay at her house
on Park you know in planfield
sleep on the floor and the you know it
was a one-bedroom apartment and I was a
[__] drug addict you know doing [__]
gigs whatever you were doing standup at
this point yeah if that's what you call
it but two years I was a hustler I used
to book one nighters so I can get on
stage okay and other guy's booking one
nighters we would trade I always hustle
yeah in the city or is this in Jersey
okay it was in Jersey yeah but if there
was a guy a comic in Long Island book in
one one nighters I would have him do my
room then you go do his he go over there
and do his you know so I H as a comic I
hustled I remember sitting with a some
agent or whatever and I go I'm going to
be [__] big at this one day I was
arrogant I don't know why I was [__]
I stunk I stunk up to about a week and a
half ago uh until that special tap baby
yeah so we had no money I never had
money like if I needed new sneakers I
would rip my sneakers and go to and I I
my mom had no money yeah you know she
had no [__] money
uh you know and when did you start
working
uh well my grandfather who owned the
house was a contractor okay so I started
working for him how old uh well the
first year I was 16 but we got a couple
miles in the car and I threw up I got
car sick and he took me home so I went
back I went back not cut out for manual
labor didn't even make it to the
job yeah I wasn't really so put the hard
hat on so I I I you know I guess 17 18
you know then my cousin took over the
business he was a [__] [__] you
know but I don't get along with the
family do you rich some of them I
wouldn't let me throw up
anywhere I mean you know remodeling from
my and then I started my I had the
biggest painting business in my town you
did at when I was 22 I mean I
had seven or eight guys working for me
back then at like $8 an hour okay so and
we were
doing major Victorian houses big vict
inside outside the whole mostly outside
but I would do some inside work uh I
mean I would you know you're still on
the junk at this point too right no I'm
just partying okay I'm not you're not
full-blown addict you're weekend warrior
yeah no no I'm getting I'm partying
everything we're going to bars and
picking up man painters always playing
fast and loose they're Sting the bar
they got paint really man I'm telling
you HH I I would I had long [__] I could
show you pictures my hair was down I
[__] up teeth and man I was getting P
girls were throwing [__] at anyhow uh
this was back you know in the throw
[__] such an old dude
turn there was oh [__] I was swatting
[__] away okay I mean I would end up
[__] girls that look like him
sometimes from behind I'd walk up and go
hey and they turn around go [__] it
H God kid what's talk about fume shout
out to the F baby gang as we know when
you're stuck in the bad habit Loop it
could sometime feel impossible to break
free and that's where fume comes in
you'll push in the right direction you
know what I mean there Q ball fume let
you keep the habit but gets rid of the
bad the Innovative award nominated
device uses Air instead of vapor there's
no electronic parts or charge and uses
all natural flavors instead of harmful
chemicals what do we doing yeah it's a
better Choice all around uh F's been a
big supporter of the show we we've since
jump since Jump Street they've always
been setting this stuff it's fantastic
little easy peasy handheld thing works
with the thing the oral fix fixation all
the stuff it checks a lot of boxes for
you um so your fume comes with
adjustable airflow dial that is designed
with movable parts and magnets for
fidgeting uh stopping is something we
all put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fum has served over 100,000
customers and have thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that can't
be you you choose join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup with
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today there you go head to
tume.in pack today that's trium f.com
and the code garbage to save an
additional 10% off your order do it gang
K this is Adam and Eve baby buddy I'm
chubbing up right now somebody turned up
my butt plug will you see them videos
haty Machi you can make them for
yourself at home and gang that brings up
a good point cuz if you're going to jam
something up your ass you want to do it
from a trusted company you know what I
mean you don't want to just grab
something off the street like you do a
purse downtown or something like that
you don't want to be mushing your wean
and knock off product you want to know
where you're getting it from an Adam and
Eve trusted company for how many years
50 years my God it's a lot of but holes
gang they send everything right to your
door it's a good it's a good way to have
a little fun in the bedroom with your
loved one or [__] by yourself whatever
yeah we joke but they they've gotten
everything if you're into heavy stuff bu
plugs dildos or if you're into the light
stuff Lubes and lingeries whatever jack
rabbits whoer do hker don'ts tally
whackers uh they got it all the big
thing is too they got discreet shipping
so you can order whatever you want you
the blow up doll ain't going to come
blowed up it's not going to say dildos
for.net or anything it's they they got
you covered they got you covered they've
been around a long time they know what
they're doing long time they know what
they're doing yeah don't wait better
better sex is just a click away take 50%
off one item free shipping with Rush
processing if that thing can't wait you
know what I mean we all been in a pinch
that's got a lot of foreplay for that
thing to get delivered Friday night only
lasts so long uh just go to Adam and
eve.com select any one item in the code
garbage I check out this is an exclusive
offer for are you garbage listeners
there you go be sure to use code garbage
to get your discount 100% free shipping
and Rush processing that's Adam
andeve.com promo code garbage Adam
andeve.com code garbage do it gang now
back to the show back to the show I had
a big ass painting business the number
one in town Victoria we go was it called
I guess Voss is pain I don't remember
what it was called but I was a scumbag
drug you know I did I partied you know I
just apologize I did my cousin second
cousin's house and I
saw uh you know I [__] I would get
during the winter I had no money no and
I would take deposits on houses to do in
the spring cuz people want them sure and
I would spend their [__] money and
then I would take like Benjamin morans
and pour like [__] shitty paint holy
[__] dude I never I've heard of that in
the bar business with vodka I
respect he's keeping the plat spinning
I'll tell you another business I
had anyhow
so swaping swaping paint just got a big
bucket of white out paint the house and
by the time we're driving away it's
peeling we were
painting I was painting a funeral home
we did it every year cuz it was big just
and they had this awning that and
[__] and I was friends with a family
a big Funeral Home in my town he goes I
don't give a [__] what you do not get
paint on this awning this is a [__]
gigantic awning do not get paint on this
so we put drop CLS we made it look
there's no way we were getting pain on
this [__] we dropped a plank through
it no pain on that though well [__]
we were sending a plank from a ladder to
hear the wall right through the awning
hey good thing with there's drop walls
on there I know uh okay so the business
[__] up I I got into sales you know
back in the
day people were selling [__] out of
trucks meat and sea sure I remember that
even in the in the 9s you doing that I
did that for a while and then my truck
where didd you get the meet cuz I've
seen that in New York back in the day
well they used to be companies they you
go you were a subcontractor for the
company you go there and they you get
and the [__] food was amazing you
know this is when me and my two friends
had an apartment we had a nice [__]
we had the biggest Halloween parties all
we did was party and I would take like a
steak out of every box or some crab like
I short the [__] people that [__]
we'd have a nice steak you know like oh
wow this these these stuffed mushrooms
feel light yeah that's cuz you're doing
on rocks so I mean the food was amaz so
one time I can of paint in there I
brought swear these clams are Benjamin
Moore I
swear so I brought anyhow my car got
robbed my truck okay I know who did it
it was a heroin addict I couldn't uh you
know and the company came after me and
then so I was out of that so then we
started me and my roommate this business
was [__] amazing this is a good story
I took that idea of selling meat and I
would rent fans and we went and got
hanging plants wholesale from The
Growers MH okay from you know and we
would pitch we'd walk into a salon with
like [__] six hanging plants and hey
we got hang and they would selling like
[__] crazy that's a pretty good
hustle and like especially back then
Hing plants are all to R hey thr us in a
corner lamban yeah I would be at the
strip mall and and I have the plants out
and I'm pitching people and then I drop
my partner off and he'd come walking up
and he would buy like three then
everybody starts buying my best one got
to create the man baby it's I'm telling
you my best one was we I got [__] we're
pitching people on the street usually go
and but sometimes you pitch people on
the street I imagine you had to be
pretty good at that if you didn't become
a comic you would have been he's a
smooth
you become Billy ma no they uh I was
offered I we went in Merl Lynch and the
guy goes I'll hire you today if you want
to be a stock broker I'd be either a
millionaire or in jail for Insider tra
sure I the ladder probably yeah yeah if
I picking up on this I mean the painting
business went B yeah they raided his
house they found a bunch of house plants
and a bunch of
stakes and Benjamin Mor can so one time
we're pitching people on the
street and I see his car pull up
and it it said MD plates so we had just
right but we had one hanging plant in
the van that was bigger it cost me $10
or 12 he comes out he goes what do you
got here I own plants we're selling
plants he goes what's that in the van I
go don't worry about that take a look at
these sure that's it and then he's like
no what do you got in the van I go
look that's expensive what do you want
here he goes no what's in the and he for
a guy like I go I go that's like a $150
pl we usually sell those to lawyers and
doctors but I saw as MD plates and that
[__] ego bought a $10 plant for like
150 F I was [__] the man that day
yeah I couldn't tell you [__] I was I
felt like a club owner in Philly
I so uh you know so I always had
businesses and but they always failed
like the plants I I I got to run into
that guy pay him I I you still owe
somebody money 2,000 for the plants all
I owed paint every paint store money
because they gave me credit you know I
was a [__] up that was 30 years ago when
you got sober did you go back and do
that like write the wrongs is that part
of that you're like you got to run into
that guy I skipped that
uh I thought he made it seem like I got
to bump into that guy it seemed like a
did you ever fix the awning at the
funeral home they did the thing is with
the paint stores I owed I with my
ex-wife we filed bankruptcy so all that
was a race sure nice that was a race
with my ex-wife and I had good credit
back then uh how's the credit now over
800 you're talking M Voss One S One
S he you dropped the second
s that guy's a bum leave off the last s
for savings
brother so so that guy died in the house
fire we had one of those uh so so okay
all that was erased but if I ever did
run into the plant guy I told him
something should break him off there you
go you're a good guy no I would I feel
you know look a dude came up like when
we had an apartment in
roommates one of my I was
missing $700 was stolen out of my room
I'm like [__] and I blame one room and
it wasn't him then years later this dude
who was a roommate of mine and I was
already sober it's getting sober he goes
Hey listen I got to I stole the money I
go well it's good don't drink yeah you
know yeah we all we all did [__] up [__]
when we were high and you know I was a
[__] up but I it's so weird I grew up
with nothing I listen don't get me wrong
I had a roof over my head my mom you
know whether it would be [__] tuna
and peas on toast which was delicious
yeah that ain't bad tuna and peas it's
all right whatever it was called on with
cream cream tuna yeah with peas was
[__] off you know uh so she did the
best she
could I
myself I guess you could I I I I gave my
kids pretty much everything they needed
in life great and my two older daughters
who are pregnant now both have houses
you know uh both marri I mean my one
daughter married a black dude but he's
lightskinned uh I'm only kid am I
allowed to say that he doesn't care he
has no sneaker game uh he
[Laughter]
mids no you know my older daughters are
they're doing great you you gave them a
life you couldn't have very ADM and my
16-year-old is I mean her room's a mess
and you know whatever uh but she's a
straight A student great you know
Bonnie's a great mom uh they're fighting
now her and my daughter she's not
talking to which makes me happy because
she's talking to me there you go you
know hey look I don't know what you did
Bon you [__] up but she does she's not
mad at me hey I'm on your side kid I
don't know what's going on so I'm you
know
everything worked out my parents I all
the dysfunction I grew up with and
that's you know this is Cookie Cutters
I'm like I'm not going deep I mean you
know obviously you
know it's just you
know anybody dealing with a a single mom
raising three kids it's tough it's tough
for her tougher especially with no real
education mhm luckily we had my
grandparents that took
us system you know but after they died
in the house so she was on her own but
we were older uh any pets going back we
had a one dog SP uh well back when I was
a little kid when I remember my dad
would I guess he was living with us I
remember him waking me up one
night and he goes come with me and we we
had this gigantic apartment but there
was a porch that went all the way around
and my went and I I go sleeping every
night hearing noises scared to death you
know sure and he woke me up and it was a
train set the size of a and I'm looking
at maaz and going man I don't even like
trains but it was the fact he get a
couple bucks at the paint store for that
it was he said to you know and when he
was around I mean he was cool he would I
don't know he would take me places I
guess he was gam you know that's where I
probably picked up my all my bad habits
yeah yeah my grandfather was a big
Gambler uh and you said your dad was in
and out what did he do for a living was
he in the area always always something I
me it's last 40 years probably was a a
travel agent but okay there was a it was
funny he he brought me home a signed
album from Tom Jones oh wow friends with
and this some young Tom Jones yeah so
I'm doing OA radio I mean I'm doing
Norton Tim and Sam
I do all the big radio shows and uh I
text him this morning I go how bad is
morning radio that I'm listening to you
two [__] zeros uh shout out to Jim
and of course I love him he was the best
man at my wedding Jim anyhow uh Tom
Jones so you know Tom Jones so Tom Jones
was doing radio I go my dad said he was
friends with you or knew you Joe Voss he
goes Joe is your dad no [__] he goes
yeah we used to party he used to bring
the girls I'm going that [__] scumbag
was L than my mom he used to he used to
throw parties in Vegas and we all you
know no [__] then he started he was in a
car he was always in some kind of scammy
business or some [__] sounds familiar
app don't fall too far from the tree
there Rich okay all right [__] Google
ey shut your mouth uh
Google [__] I'll take it [__] I'm
being I'm being smashed by an owl
you [__] look at my chest and tell me
if I have a spot x-ray [__] Vision
eyes being smashed by H it's funny so
you know but listen you know in life
uhhuh and this is you are where you are
when you're supposed to be there yeah if
you believe that everything
everything look everything in life that
I've been through drug addiction
recovery divorce
kids to me is what made me a better
comic not saying I I don't want to say
great even though I am I don't want to
say it because some people think he's an
arrogant you know you know [__] guys
like him oh I wish I was listen someday
you could be uh who's he talking to Toby
yeah I'm looking at Toby guys likey
you're still talking to still talking to
Tom
Jones you know what I mean so uh and to
me you know some of the best comics and
to me I mean there's all kinds of styles
but are comics from here sure that live
the life yeah that you get you when you
walk away you you make a connection with
them emotionally you were like oh I was
in a moment like that I've reacted like
that to certain things yeah of course
it's emotional you know them like you
can walk away from some Comics go they
were funny what do he say I don't know I
don't know you know like you if you you
watch St hope you'll go I'll never be
that funny as long as I live he's so
unique yeah and there's so many great
Comics that I watch you know meter's
[__] really you know I saw this guy
Chris Porter I watch him and I don't
usually watch com [__] Shane used to
open for me play out to gly he's a whole
another level you know you watch Maria
banford people might not like her but
she's [__] brilliant she's [__]
great has been for a while super
talented my wife so many people have
stole her style throughout the years oh
my wife style she's mhm she's an icon
you know for female Comics uh so and but
there's Comics that like you watch
somebody like Brian rean who is as funny
as anybody alive you know but if people
don't know him they go what the [__] is
this guy
crazy shout out to but if you if you're
no comment and you're watching him or
you're his fan or whatever you're going
you can't get funnier than yeah of
course and but he's the complete
opposite of Someone Like A stanh hope
yeah gotcha or a Patrice or you know
so good comedy is good comedy you know I
mean look people make fun of car Tom
he's the best prop actor is sure if
you're going to do something be the best
yeah you know no I agree he's got he's
been in Vegas for who knows how many
years millions of dollar prob wres 400
jokes a year Millions so you know
whatever um any family vacations mixed
in there at all when you were a kid do
the Jersey sure you squeeze anything out
yeah they would drive us my aunts owned
houses in Beach Haven Long Beach is okay
so they let us come for a week MH well
there was one time I think we rented a
house when my father and mother I think
we're together together yeah the old
[__] big Chevy round cars I remember
driving down the beach but any vacation
was
if uh my aunt let us stay at the house
stay at the house you know we always
look my aunt I had an aunt and an uncle
my mother had a brother and a sister and
their
families did very well we were the black
sheep of the family sure and I was the
blacker sheep of the black she you know
I was family dinners they make fun of
you know what I mean with all the
cousins uh any time I talk like this it
gives me [__] anxiety cuz you're
getting real you're talking about your
life yeah yeah I'm having a [__]
anxiety attack just let me drink more
coffee that'll help some more cold brew
in here for Voss so uh not really family
vacation I did get get to go to Camp one
year not sleepover just just a day camp
or so we went to the playground as kids
yeah you know we every neighborhood had
a playground in the summer play knock
hockey and tether ball and baseball sure
go to the playground that's all we did
as kids I feel like all your vacations
circled around waiting till the heat
died down yeah yeah to
respond what the [__] is
what I I think I get that but I like I
like you I think you're a good
kid I think you're a good kid man all
time ball man no I'm sorry is he talking
to me what's this guy's deal Jes [__]
what the what happened to
respect you're stealing house plants
what are you talking
about selling bad meat the side of the
road and skim it off the top yeah well
look it you got to get you got to
survive yeah yeah you got to cover rent
baby uh no we didn't have vacations as a
kid you know he and let's move out of
that doing very well now yeah let's move
to once you once you became once you
started your legendary status as Rich
Voss once you started doing well in
comedy what what what about it when did
I show yeah what year is that oh uh what
was your first big year what was your
first Big Year check and did you make
any stupid purch I think the biggest
year the first biggest I was doing TV
shows like evening at The Improv lot of
those ComEd Road all those dumb you know
but Comedy Jam yeah yeah I I was the
first white guy on that I did deconomy
jam and I call clubs and hey I I did Def
we don't use those acts here you know
the white clubs I'm sorry I'm not
[__] earthquake or you know a natural
disaster I'm rich I'm just trying to you
know but there was a I was doing Urban
rooms back then M you know and but I did
when it came to that you know de Jam uh
the Apollo BT I did everything you could
do and was Last Comic Standing that was
the biggest okay so I was doing
OA and they were big back then they were
huge were [__] big they were as big
as you can get and I would and tough
crowd and then I was offered Last Comic
and I go I don't think I'm going to do
this reality I don't know you know and
it would have been the biggest mistake
of my life MH cuz after I did I mean it
was the first season of uh Last Comic it
was so [__] big we any everywhere I
would go places it was making people
yeah people would recognize you know my
daughters were getting so mad they were
young quit staring at them you know we
go places they didn't know they were I
don't know 13 14 or 12 and uh so I you
know I had Last Comic Standing tough
crowd on Anda all at the same time and
when you have three big things at the
same time [__] so but I would never
move to LA and leave my kids I said I'm
staying in New York you know you were
living in the city at the time or in
Jersey I in Jersey so you so you're
you're married to your first wife right
no we were separated you guys were
already separated okay I was living in a
third floor apartment and you know and
going on the road and doing whatever
yeah and then
uh how did it work uh you know I just
milked everything going on tour the road
I mean now I'm making real
money so for we did eight month eight or
10 months me Corey and Dave from last
Comic which I set up the tour through
the agent I had at the time who I'm
who's the biggest agent in the business
now uh burkowitz he used to work for
Dorfman who was my manag
whatever we were selling out Thursday
night two shows on a Thursday like
distress six 700 people just making
stupid money for me back then yeah so
that kind of died down but then I'm
still on the road by myself and the
other two I was on the road with they
had you know they were kind of like
padas they thought that I knew it wasn't
going to last and they're [__] hey
you know where's our M&M's or whatever
you know what I mean I go look I was
already headlining this place don't [__]
this up for me we got a good thing going
and I stole the M I stole I switched the
green ones so for blue I told so so when
those when those checks were rolling in
was there any dumb purchases did you go
out buy jewelry a car a house he's
wearing four Super Bowl rings right now
what are you talking about I've never
seen anybody wear five I was at OA and
we were going to do a tour the tour
we're going I went and bought a Mercedes
before the tour before the tour that's
dirt bag logic and I love it dude love
it yes I put a Mercedes and then the
next day cuz the sex that church sex
thing they got cancelled a day after I
bought my Mercedes the [__] tour was
out the window driving around in a
[__] C class and the car was he's got
plants in the back seat the car was
found burning planfield it's uh so okay
was that your first nice
car cuz you like you like nice things
you do which I which I've always
respected about you unab bashfully love
nice things we're going to get into it
you had humble beginnings but you do
have a lot of class in you got a rol the
on now it might be fake I'm not sure no
no my teeth cost 70,000 is that what you
paid for no yes they look great they
look great so yeah I do like I didn't Ro
brags about the te I love it that's old
school New Jersey Jewish guy see that
Muller right there that's 5 G's okay huh
I had a sell out three funny bones pulls
out corn on the cop these ain't going
nowhere the Mercedes was the first nice
car you got first real yeah I had a
shitty Mercedes before that cuz Patrice
had a Cadillac I go well [__]
him the shitty Mercedes those five
trying to outdo each other must have
been [__] great so then I got the
real shows up with a jet fighter know he
showed up with
Kevin so I I uh when yeah it was a brand
new Mercedes that's great and you bought
it you didn't lease it I don't lease you
don't lease no I'm a buyer leasing is
like [__] rented I you buy to me you
buy a house you don't rent I rent it for
years you know I mean I guess if you're
a New York whatever but listen we just
sold our last house because we bought a
new one this summer big [__] built-in
pool in ground pool I don't know what
you call it I grew up we call them
built-in uh you know [__] big ass
house you know and we sold our other
house and I made profit you can't make
profit renting true gotcha you know you
can't make profit rent and
leasing they're making money they want
people to lease because whatever it's no
yeah yeah what happened to the Mercedes
did you sell it or just hang on a better
car have you did you ever regress back
out of Merced or what do you driving now
you're driving to Mercedes now Lexus
yeah you did have a beamer for a while I
remember the Beamer car guys this is how
empty I am I bought a [__] brand new
Lexus last year the ES350 the big one I
went in to get it serviced it wasn't
even 11 months old and I went in I guess
I was depressed that day and I walked
out with a newer one and traded it in I
respect it this guy you're me for came
out with a new car it came out with the
sports one something to fill the time
baby yeah I was I was just in uh out
west I played Pebble Beach and he I I I
meet the richest golfers on the planet I
friends semi Club whatever and they're
letting me use their Audi for a week I
almost came home with an Audi and bought
an Audi I almost did I go you haven't
even had your new Lexus for [__] six
months I pay it off too I don't owe
nothing on it you know oh you buy them
cash no I I go in trade in my other car
so get whatever whatever out of go 10
grand or whatever I got a 10 grand
payment so each month I send 1,000 bucks
a month for 10 months and you knock it
out so I don't know anything on my leg
but now our [__] mortgage doubled
from my last mortgage but the [__]
house is big house it's let me see if I
have a picture of just part of my
waiting room in the basement it's is
just one of the rooms waiting room in
the basement are you kidding you got an
orthodontist down there no my wait room
oh your wait room why what you I think
you in a waiting room I'm like the [__]
you doing in there r you ran half of it
out you put in a green room in the
house wait wait here's oh this is out
that's very nice this is out by the pool
wow wait a second oh that's a nice pool
my wife look she grew up on a sleeping
on dirt floors she grew up poor j [__]
in Canada she was a farmer she had to go
have an operation and her parents put
her on the bus and sent her across the
country by herself at like 12 years old
to have her [__] one of her organs
taken out Jes cuz they had they couldn't
leave cuz they had to farm and it was
cropping season so they so yeah so you
upgraded you're upgraded is there
anything you got the pool the pool was
already in yeah and did you put the
weight room in yourself or was there
already well I had a weight room no I
built I had I built it myself now what
the [__] where is it you know this is
really we believe you that's me and
Clint
Eastwood me and Clint East that guy's
homeless that's he's not you got to
clean them glasses not the house I did I
did oh wait that's me and Clint here's a
picture of Tom this is part of my weight
room okay yeah like a gym got the heavy
bag you hitting the heavy bag no I hit
my
wife that was coming I knew I was coming
what a hack
sorry man uh yeah you know the
it's I I the do you like the upgrade
well I do but more responsibility a
bigger n at the end of the month yeah my
wife's career well now this writer
strikes [__] her up but she after the
writer she's supposed to have a TV show
in Canada based on her life growing up
okay on her book I got to finish it
[__] seven years ago find out how it
end it
yeah you get divorced what the [__] it's
hard reading a book you know and she
slept with him
too so Jesus Christ No Boundaries [__]
uh fny so you know she you know she goes
listen she she goes look you're white
trash to me she goes you got to pull
yourself out of the mud you know she
goes you [__]
think I go up you know listen I I grew
up where I don't want look we sold our
house and we got a big check I have a
$500 winning lottery ticket that I can't
wait to cash doesn't even come close to
the money that I that I deposit this
morning but I won this you like the
action he he likes a deal how rich boss
wants to wet his beak on something the
daily number Hits different I don't know
what to tell you yeah hit what are you
kidding me I won one out of two games
yesterday was happy [__] half a point
to Rams last minute field goal Jesus
Christ how many are you buying lottery
tickets every
day yeah you go so you go scratchers
yeah here's my goal what do you drop a
day on lottery tickets are you the guy
in front of me at the counter going give
me 8
9623 not maybe 6070 a day maybe $607 a
day 60 70 bucks you're like an old lady
wait is that on scratch or you playing
numbers numbers too numbers too numbers
and scratch but I I'm I quit not an
[__] do you I treat me with some
respect do you have your numbers too you
know got to say them but you got your
numbers yeah you go up so like one two
three box
straight and then I told like if I worse
is when you go in in they repeated same
place right you go to the same you go to
your same spot yeah but I get so mad at
them because I'll tell them a number and
they'll [__] and I used to do this
bit on stage it's hacking now but it's
true they'll say the wrong number I'm
like don't [__] repeat them wrong cuz
now I got to play the number they said
sure now you hear that number bad luck
if you don't play that number if I hear
other people in if I hear other people
in there saying numbers I get out cuz I
don't want to hear their numbers cuz I
got to play their [__] dumb numbers
you're a different kind of trash I love
it man that's awesome you're still doing
70 bucks a day scratch what youo
spreading it around what are you
scratching the scratchers with do you
have a a dime always yeah quarter is too
big it's too clunky dime slides that
[__] right off the [__] paper now do
you play the whole game or do you just
SC you just scratch when I got to play
the game you play the game yeah I'm not
I'm not sick oh I'm sorry do you do them
there in the store or do you wait till
you get home and then sit down car go
back to the car yeah my wife goes wait
till we get home I go no this is where
we do them mhm okay he's like an old
lady playing bingo this [__] gu I
love it you know here's my it's a [__]
up fantasy what's the biggest you ever
hit if you don't mind me
asking uh what's the biggest I hit
probably four grand five you know I
don't know oh for a while I was hitting
big I won like five nights in a row I
won like thir I was hitting numbers like
a [__] this weekend I hit Friday
and Saturday night in New York really
two nights in a row yeah two nights in
you play Jersey and New York anywhere I
am at when I drive to [__] Baltimore
I'll have [__] Jersey Pennsylvania
Delaware Maryland you got man not going
to drive through sorry I'm not going to
drive through Delaware then look and go
oh [__] one of my numbers came out I get
it I assume when the powerball's up you
you play that when it's like the two two
billion or whatever it is I play it if
it was [__] whatever are you kid he's
a dude he's in I love it but you know
what it sounds bitter and I'm not I I
love doing comedy but I just want to hit
a scratch off says a million dollar
winner take a picture of it and go look
I want to a million dollars it's not
enough to quit comedy but it's enough to
tell 10 club Owners go [__]
themselves that's all that's all I'm
looking
for uh boy talk about hanging resentment
Let It Go uh no I so you're still
playing scratchers yeah not I I quit on
Mondays usually start back Thursday okay
that's not bad that's not bad but I play
number numbers you know like the number
yeah yeah yeah the the pick three you
got the Louis Vuitton wallet this guy
this [__] guy like with his numbers
in it no the only guy no other Louis
Vuitton wallet has the numbers in
it
I mean you're [__] something else
rich I parked in the parking lot and I
looked at what it cost to park and I
wanted to go to the guy listen why don't
we just do this and off the books off
the books and I'll give you 50 cash but
I didn't have time I wanted to run up I
didn't have time to negotiate with
listen I'll spend 500 on dinner but
still I'll go to a garage sale I went to
one this week my friend said go to this
they're selling golf club and I I drive
there and it was [__] and I [__] go
you just wasted 40 minutes on my
Saturday morning are you in the market
for golf clubs or you just no I I got
two sets I want to dump I was going to
sell I had three and a friend of mine I
was he's big on the golf a friend and
you're we were just talking about this
you're are you what you're a pretty good
player right not this year I am but I
lost it's come it'll come back what's
your average or whatever it's called my
hand I mean I I was shooting low to
Middle 80s it's great so you would beat
most other Comics some
but now I'm not I'm I just lost it'll
come back I I'm doing something [__]
up uh God it I I what kind of what kind
of sticks you got what I got what you
got what do you got Callaway well I'm a
Callaway I got two sets of Cal I got
Apex and epics I might go try some do
you play g i I played this week I play a
couple times a year this my friend I
this millionaire he sends me he just
sent me this one driver it's worth a th
the the shaft is worth 750 but he sent
me this putter it's worth 5 to 7,000 I
got it in the case it's a it's a Scotty
Cameron only 100 made Beach you know uh
this other couple friends of
mine I flew out to uh San I did San Jose
three nights there then they paid for me
to go into the Clint Eastwood Golf
Tournament
okay uh
you know and I'm playing Pebble Beach
these people are I'm sitting next I'm
really billionaires million and billion
but couple of that put me up at their
house their friend you know she's doing
scratchers at the table you guys got a
dime don't think I didn't buy lot of
numbers in LA in California but they're
so nice you know uh I met one lady when
we had our radio show hey I see her in
La you want she took me to belir MH we
became friends her and
IA we're having a lunch at belir and she
goes my father won five Oscars and her
father's John Douglas the composer I
don't know he I'm an idiot he [__]
Star Wars Schindler's List he he's the
biggest composer five Oscars that's a
lot okay it's not you know what I mean
it's not you mean John Williams yeah
what did I say Douglas I said John
Douglas yeah John Douglas I'm a [__]
[__] John Williams joh Star Wars
Boozled you no John John Doug cavetti
you don't know who he is huh from Bon
John Douglas wrote all the profiling
books he was a profiler for the FBI John
John Williams Sor gotcha uh god what the
[__] I'm smashing him for my for my
stupidity Jesus Christ now he's going to
go back and tell all his Bringers hey
guess how dumb Voss
is sorry hey you don't have any uh
crystalite do you to pour in here we got
liquid IV Chom Cod garbage why that's a
question though do you drink crystalite
once in a while to make sometimes I'll
squeeze lemon in my water okay I like
two very different things Crystal Light
yeah no I like Crystal Light too uh it's
probably going to get me sick where you
food shopping now at the new house yeah
let's get into some garbage cues here
okay whatever you
need I want to know more about rituals
where where you food chopping now you're
in the new neighborhood the same we were
2 miles from our other house okay what
do you go to shop right you go to shoppr
once in a while once in a while we'll
head over to Wegman's okay if the number
hits you H WG you got WG and if we're in
the area I go for coffee Whole Foods you
can get the the $5 for a bag at Whole
Foods get for the bag of coffee bofe
they have good coffee I I'll go to
Dunkin' donuts and get bags but there's
only one CU you can get four for a
certain price the other ones are [__]
whacking you out but really driving
around town no I got to pass it I'm not
going out of my way okay uh our
anniversary was uh what's today oh
yesterday I took my wife out for dinner
I go we'll stop it DG and they were
closed I was very upset are you doing
the grocery shopping will you go and do
the order for the week huh will you go
and do the order for the week [__]
headlin not bagging my own groceries
I'll go pick up stuff for my you know
that I want you know to take the golf or
whatever sure okay you know uh she
orders it now has a delivery got that's
what a lot of people are doing yeah the
other day they brought the wrong order
and my wife call said this is somebody
else's order and they go we'll keep it
they can't take it back yeah look you I
know and you know and she's upset cuz I
had pool guys come and clean the pool
and do some [__] she goes look at them
pool guys are supposed to be hot so I
wrote to me and him out there I wrote
this I go listen it's a funny new bit I
go listen uh we've been married 18 years
I go look if you're [__] somebody
having an affair just be honest and tell
me so I can get
hard hey that's a good bit did you did
you hear the uh Proctologist joke about
the Proctologist oh this is a good one
I'm not all of a sudden I'm Jackie the
[__] this guy goes in for his first
prostate check MH folks I don't tell
jokes on stage I do bits I got seven
albums still got a to get a this guy
goes in to get his first prostate check
doctor goes look I know this is your
first time I'm GNA put two fingers in
your ass and twirl it around try not to
get hard Tom and the guy goes my name's
not Tom and the doctor goes I was
talking to
myself it's a good one love a good
Street joke isn't that a good one that's
great all right okay what else do you
want to know yeah we go okay you shop
and Shop Right what are the what are the
you mentioned you'll go and get stuff
that you want what are the are are there
Rich only items items in the house that
like everybody knows that they're
they're dads yeah yeah what would they
be what are you snacking on at the house
well I I like getting at Costco the
sixpack of can of sardines because when
you play golf or in your car you could
have just in case of emergency sardines
you break down I got two survival
backpacks in the trunk wait break hold
on thought you're going to say like rits
or cookies no one's ever had emergency
sardines it's not the 20s em you like
that's what you're eating at the house
no no I'll take those on the golf course
if I the last minute if so you're
telling me you're at Pebble Beach you're
cracking open a can of anies no I was on
the road not when I travel when I travel
you know but when you go play golf in
the in your hometown BR chall you know
if I don't have a sandwich just in case
of emergency and you'll just eat the
sardines right out of the the thing well
I bring a fork no crackers or anything
sometimes if we have them if not I'll
eat them straight up but they got to be
boneless I don't like the ones with the
bones you don't you ever have sardin
yeah that'd be gross you ever I mean
like
a man I that was a great throw away
great at like uh you know like a Greek
restaurant I'll get like you know the
the fried sardines you have them on the
third hole did you ever uh fry baloney
yeah yeah we did fry balone that's good
that [__] was good man are you cooking
it all at the house breakfast anything I
don't know I'm asking uh once in a while
I'll make an egg or two for myself if
I'm in a I'm trying to eat better now
gotcha you know I was out in with these
people this week and we went to
restaurants every night and I'm eating
like a maniac you know who's picking up
the check when you guys go out how do
you work that out who me and Bonnie no
no when you go out with like other
couples I picked up breakfast and lunch
but not dinner there was like 14 people
I'm not [__] spending 2,000 other
people I don't know I don't even drink
they're [__] drinking that's the
whole point yeah doing bottles of wine
and [__] then you're paying for it no I
but if I go out with you know I'll pick
up with friends or Comics I I got you
know whatever let's say you and Keith
went out to dinner who's picking up that
check well he
[Laughter]
can't man that's
that was quick and mean the rich Voss
the rich Voss way well he's mean no of
course I know uh you know it depends me
Bobby no I'll pick it
up whatever no one's no one's keeping
score gotcha okay when if you go out to
a steakhous how do you get your steak
your steak we went out last night I
don't want to say the name of the place
say it for me and no because I I got
chicken porn but it's a well-known steak
place and I'm not lying it was not good
it was tasteless I what are you getting
chicken porn at a steak place I don't
eat red meat ah okay but this place the
sardines were in the
car that's what there you go there you
hey guys guess what I
said
[__] he can't just give it to you
which I respect he's a man of principal
I love it I love it I said that's
good oh je I told my friend guess I said
rich who's
that that was
funny you just got him started
now uh yeah I went out last and the
Caesar salad was great M you like a nice
seize you go out e La you know try this
listen I'm not lying you you you ever
eat the Caesar at the Celler because you
could do it not really but if you're any
way the food's unbelievable food's the
best czy yeah
put buffalo wing sauce on it not a lot
just enough little dab some buffalo wing
sauce spread it around Bonnie taught me
this but I'm taking credit because I
tell the comics uh it tastes so it's not
hot sauce it's got to be the buffalo
sauce you know if if if things are rough
and you're in a trench and you only have
hot sauce Tobasco or something you yeah
but not to so we got went out last night
for our anniversary she said she was
going to pay but I paid i' got my wallet
out faster sure it hurt uh you know I
tip big too I like to you know tip big
well
listen [__] blue collar workers have
the tough life sure they have a you know
I like if I back in if I was doing TV
like say last whatever taping the last
time we taped for uh HBO with Colin out
I I'd rather I'm talking to the work the
blue color guys not the
executives you know I'm not you know cuz
that's I could relate if I was at a
party and one side of the room was
Lawyers and doctors and the other side
uhct convicts and pimps you know it's
just whatever you feel more comfortable
you feel more comfortable that makes
sense so I yeah it I here's the thing
money I don't care but I like I don't
like so like we went out for dinner last
night and it was like 120 whatever it
was but I go $7 for a little Coke big it
like sometimes principal [__] drives
me nuts do you know what I mean like
like don't even I don't even want to
know care about the money it's just it's
frustrating that they charge me $7 for a
little Coke in a bottle a little glass
bottle on yeah they love they like to
run them up yeah and so I don't I don't
mind spending money but I'm not I'm not
a [__] don't take advant don't try to
[__] get over on sure well you do
bottled water like sparkling or still
sparkling I I I don't like that I like
sparkling water we could have got you
some I like uh pelo I like uh what's the
one I got I can't think of it but
sparking water yeah okay what are you
throwing down like say uh like one of
your nieces or nephews or somebody like
that's getting married what's usually in
the
envelope Jesus
CHR that could hold even his farts are
timed
well he's like
606 66 66 are you [__] ripped one
come on that was a good one sorry was my
back I threw my back
out 66 uh well I don't have any nieces
or nephews okay I'll take care you know
I say you were coming to one of our
weddings we're getting married a friend
another comic you know you're going I
would do a spot what's a spot 10 minutes
I picked up to
1240 uh weding you
know I don't know am I supposed like if
I know the person good friends with them
yeah good
friends uh well they'll definitely get
uh a rich FAL Legend shirt sure get a
merch package get a mer autograph CD I
know at least a couple hundred to two
two to five I guess it seems normal
right it yep that's right in the
Wheelhouse that's good you know I've
sent uh money to weddings I didn't even
go to sure that's a gentleman's move
it's a pro move I like that have you
ever left a bad Yelp review no what am I
[__] who's going to write a bad
review I get bad reviews I don't write
them I get bad oh I think I sh myself do
you have no just do you have a uh you
guys have a garage at the new house
right yes two cars do you have a second
fridge in there you have a garage fridge
oh no with like sodas and drinks and
stuff oh no we have one in our Florida
room we have a little fridge in our
Florida Florida room that's what it's
called it's like a a sun room sure sun
room it screens and I just put a TV out
there a nice table what's in the fridge
what what drinks what do you put in
there I don't put anything my uh uh wife
and kid put uh Dr Peppers for my kid Dr
Peppers lik Dr Peppers I'll give you
that yeah I like Dr Peppers that ain't
bad do you do any fast food at all yeah
you doing a blue moon but let me tell
you
something uh like Sundays all I've only
been trying to eat well for the last
couple weeks uh Popeyes that [__]
chicken popey is [__] amazing it's so
[__] good Pope the chicken sandwich
oh that and just a big chicken white
breast of oh the skin it's just oh it's
all right it's so [__] good pom Taco
Bell isn't bad and they have a little
breakfast sandwich at Taco Bell if I'm
in a hurry I'll get it okay a breakfast
burrito uh Popeyes and Taco Bell any
Mickey D's any Wendy's I once in a while
Burger K you don't do the red meat no
Burger King had the impossible burger
for a while okay and and that's you know
where does the no red meat come from
like I it's been 35 years it's just just
a [__] up my you know late at night I go
out and have chili dogs and [__] f up
yeah and I remember one time when I was
living with this girl she was smoking
but I met this girl at a club and I was
doing a show somewhere and next thing
you know I'm fooling around with this
other girl get I'm going a [__] uh so I
go I smell like girl so I went to a red
Tower in my town and I bought a chili
dog and I'm driving home and I put some
on me with the window blowing the chili
on me right so I smell like a chili dog
and I get home and my girlfriend goes oh
you went to get Chilly Dogs and he
didn't bring me
any
so are you [__] the girl to chili dog
place yeah what the [__] uh do you want
any
suits yeah but I got to get some new
ones I I how many suits do you think you
have well they don't fit I had them
years ago I got one that fits yeah you
know I had nice uh Versace I had uh back
in the day I would assume you probably
had put it together yeah Armani no not
yeah I got an Armani I think Calvin
Klein I used to have like uh but I gave
them to Bonnie okay she she wears well
the other day we did photo shoots for
our podcast and we each put on suits and
went stood in the pool with shoots on
doing photoshops then she did one of her
floating like she's dead and I'm on my
phone you know Prett good some funny
photo uh so yeah I had but I had suits
you know uh I don't know because I got
them at Marshalls or Century 21 the
Versace the Versace I got a Century 21
Versace classic I didn't mention classic
yeah hold on a second back no the other
one by Target I think the I don't know
if it's Armani but when I was on last
Comic right we're doing the finals and
they go we want you to wear a suit I go
I I go you g to have to buy it for me
and I keep it and I said I get me an
Armani and I'll I'll wear a suit there
you go there you go strong arm yeah they
got it what about uh in the shower you
peeing in the
shower yes every time I possibly can I
don't pee in the pool you don't pee in
the pool why or the hot tub or hot tub I
don't put in a hot tub before is the hot
tub connected to the pool yeah okay oh
that's nice little waterfall going into
it that's all right look at you will you
brush your teeth up there in the shower
yeah not in the shower before I take a
shower you do okay you don't brush your
teeth in the shower all right electric
toothbrush regular toothbrush regular I
have a water a one that's you know a
water pick I use it once in a while okay
and where are you getting your color
what do you do your color what oh my
tattoos you're no your tan tan oh from
playing golf from playing golf because
you look great no tan Anning bed no no
in the winter no I got a bed back no in
the winter got a bed back he is a 66y
old Jewish guy oh my no I know not
tanning one time years ago I [__] a
girl in a tanning bed Jesus after a show
it hurt my knees why how did you end up
in a t she owned a tanning salon I
picked her up in a club the upper deck
the upper deck we went to her and I go
it's you know [__] the tanning bed
but was it on was it on no no it's I
don't think so no and I wasn't on
either I mean I I'm pretty good I'm I
mean yeah yeah this is this is all for
this is all here say at this point F
what I'm not lying no no no no we
believe you you're trash is what we're
saying oh can you whistle with your
fingers there you go what was the last
book you
read what what was the last book you
read is this guy a
cop we're here having a good time you're
jerk off friend I [__] I read most of
Bonnie's book okay yeah there we go that
makes sense okay do you fly up front you
fly first class if I get upgraded okay
but I fly I get the emergency window
exit seat okay it's a lot of room uhuh
look if you're not fing if you're flying
first
class to
La maybe houon or Vegas then the seets
are good if not they're just like any
other hard seat right you know I bring
my own little cooler I freeze a bottle
of wood and I bring my own sandwiches
you know cuz I'm not eating that [__] on
the plane what kind of sandwich are
anchovy sandwiches tell me now no
usually egg salad or tuna Egg N egg
salad on plane with a tuna sandwich no
but it's in the cooler a little cooler I
do that bit I swear to God you're eating
egg salad or tuna on a plane and do you
take pride in making your I imagine cuz
you're meticulous so you probably have a
nice probably put out a nice egg salad
sandwich I would assume [__] amazing
yeah yeah egg Sal they go last I don't
want to do the bit but it's true at TSA
you can't bring egg salad on the plane I
go I I yeah I've read all the stories of
the danger cuz it was in a sealed
container and bread she said it was okay
whatever but I'll bring my own cooler
not if I'm In First Class which is very
seldom because when I when Continental I
used to get upgraded all the time but
since United took over Continental I
never get upgrade I get upgraded to
[__] you know Rochester big [__]
deal sure yeah 20 minute flight minut
flight is United your carrier is that is
that who you go with all the time yes K
Nork yeah and what uh what plastic are
you throwing around you got an MX
American Express
card no I got uh MasterCard I should get
that one Bobby told me to get that gets
you in the other Lounge I think it's
AMX I just hate doing all the paperwork
F filling out all the I got an 800
credit score I can get it I can get it
you fat piece of [__] [__] sitting
here judging me okay [__] AMX you're
lucky you could spell it go [__]
yourself I like how that's what he got
bad
at what no no oh man yeah I
mean 100% garbage and we love you we
[__] love you I mean still doing
scratchers scratchers playing the
numbers in every stady D I've never met
anybody that swaps pain
out I mean that's crazy
tun a salad on a plane I mean you got
the new house though you're killing it
doing good true uh true American success
story Rich Voss yes thank you I 37 years
sober I was a drug addict and now uh I'm
a grandparent there you that man got a
brand new special out too 30 minutes
with Rich Voss it's out right now you
got to check it out YouTube uhr Voss or
you can go to rich.com and get it and uh
our podcast is starting back up my wife
hates me uh
you know it's wherever the [__] podast I
don't that's right where wherever you
get your pods game yeah you know it's uh
the special uh is on gonna be on YouTube
but it's going to view
master in about two weeks that joke went
nowhere what I don't know what view
Master is you put the little thing in
and that's a it would have been [__]
good if somebody somebody was older than
12 in I thought it was just I thought it
was just streaming service or something
like so did I I'm like is that to do
Netflix I'm yeah no I was happy with the
special I that's great I didn't I'm a
club comic I mean I've done theater one
of the best buddy one of the best thank
you
uh you know I it I just love doing clubs
you know what I mean yeah it's great I
mean you're a club guy like you're the
essence of you is a club guy like you're
you're you know Rough and Tumble [__]
killer check out the [__] special
gang he's a [__] uh New York City
Legend absolutely 100% 30 minutes of
Rich Voss make sure you check it out
Rich anything else you want the folks
out there to know any dates or anything
or anybody just over Rich voss.com all
my dates are there and uh you know or
just my wife hates me podcast this was
so much [__] fun buddy thanks Budd
you so happy to you happy to have you
Hey listen don't take anything personal
you know look you got to know where you
are in
life kiy what do you got for guys we're
over the road tickets are tickets are
selling out get them uh rug garbage.com
we [__] love you gang gang Rich we
love you thank you so much for coming in
yeah gang we love you and we'll see you
next week peace